el servicio de limpieza miranda cobra 2
mil 800 pesos por limpiar ocho oficinas
cuál es el precio que cobra la compañía
por limpiar una oficina entonces
queremos el precio que cobra la compañía
por limpiar una oficina vamos a escribir
esto como razones nos están diciendo que
cobra dos mil ochocientos pesos
no voy a poner así dos mil ochocientos
pesos pesos por limpiar ocho oficinas
entonces abajo le voy a poner ocho
oficinas oficinas oficinas y lo que
queremos hacer es simplificar esta pues
digamos razón de precio vale cómo le
hacemos para simplificar pues no tenemos
que el denominador es divisible entre 8
y el numerador también 2000 es divisible
entre 8 800 es divisible entre 8 vamos a
ver cuánto nos queda la división vale la
voy a hacer aquí del lado derecho con
color amarillo queremos dos mil 800
entre entre 8 la división de casita 8
caben dos tres veces en 28 3 por 8 es 24
y 428 24 es 4 y baja el 0 aquí nos queda
55 por 840 búsqueda 40 lo restamos se
hace 0 baja el 0 aquí nos queda un 0 y
por lo tanto 2800 entre 8 es 350 de esta
forma este de acá lo podemos cambiar por
un 350 y dividiendo el denominador entre
8 aquí nos queda uno entonces esta razón
de precio nos queda igual había a 350
entre 1 pesos pesos por oficina oficina
oficina que también lo podemos escribir
lo podemos escribir como 350 pesos pesos
por oficina o si si